Shure: 你给的是那个靖蝎啊
Shure: You're giving him the wrong Scorpion.
Tasha: 哎呀哎呀
Tasha: Oh my, oh my.
Shure: 你被这种人
Shure: You were taken by someone like this.
Nicous: 已经红了不知道
Nicous: Already popular, you don't know.
Nicous: 你追个三星的还可以
Nicous: You can still chase a 3-star.
俢硕：来了
Shure: Here it comes.
Tasha: 就差几个立场足
Tasha: Just a few more stances.
Katrina: 就往就往这上面放你想要压的就行
Katrina: Just place it here, wherever you want it.
Tasha: 一个两个还差一个立场足
Tasha: One, two, just need one more stance.
Tasha: 还差一个无敌啊
Tasha: Still need one invincible.
Katrina: 这个我感觉也这样吧
Katrina: I think this is fine too.
Katrina: 就这样摆着就行
Katrina: Just place it like this.
Tasha: 哈哈他他打不过我
Tasha: Haha, he can't beat me.
Tasha: 然后他还可以再跟我玩
Tasha: Then he can still play with me.
Katrina: 你那里有几片啊Lucy
Katrina: How many pieces do you have, Lucia?
Lucia: 嗯我下下面那个是4片
Lucia: Hmm, I have four pieces below.
Lucia: 不过是小的
Lucia: But they're small.
Lucia: 上面只有
Lucia: Only on the top.
Tasha: 嗯是的
Tasha: Hmm, yes.
Lucia: 我打算先放两个
Lucia: I plan to place two first.
Katrina: 我说因为木板啊
Katrina: I'm talking about the wooden boards.
Lucia: 木板木板只有一个
Lucia: There's only one wooden board.
Tasha: 嗯乌迪尔
Tasha: Hmm, Udyr.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不过纸有很多
Lucia: But there's a lot of paper.
Nicous: 乌迪尔差一个
Nicous: Udyr is missing one.
Tasha: 123 嗯
Tasha: 123, hmm.
Tasha: 内脏桌也差一个
Tasha: The organ table is also missing one.
Shure: 然后这个可以摘是吗
Shure: And can this be plucked?
Katrina: 可以啊但感觉这叶子不是很好看
Katrina: Yes, but I feel like these leaves don't look good.
Nicous: 卖了卖了卖了卖了
Nicous: Sell it, sell it, sell it.
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Sell to whom?
Katrina: 这种小花就可以直接摘
Katrina: You can just pluck these little flowers directly.
Jake:怎么还
Jake: How come?
Tasha: 谁卖谁啊
Tasha: Who's selling to whom?
Jake:还你是挂了吗
Jake: Are you dead?
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Sell to whom?
Katrina: 我天呐
Katrina: Oh my God.
Jake:现在就剩他和人机打的
Jake: Now it's just him and the bot fighting.
Katrina: 从小幼儿园的时候上手工课就不会做
Katrina: Since kindergarten, I couldn't do crafts.
Shure: 就不听
Shure: Just don't listen.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就给糖给别人让别人做
Katrina: I would give candy to others to do it for me.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 从小就会
Katrina: I've known since I was a kid.
Katrina: 这种雇佣劳动力
Katrina: This kind of hired labor.
Tasha: 嗯应该不会吧
Tasha: Hmm, it shouldn't be, right?
Katrina: 然后就很多年没有做过手了
Katrina: And then I haven't done crafts for many years.
Shure: 这压出来是一整张是吗
Shure: Does it press out into a whole sheet?
Katrina: 没有压出来
Katrina: It didn't press out.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: It's just...
Lucia: 像这样
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia: 就是它会变成一个一个干
Lucia: It turns into a dry piece.
俢硕：啊 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Nicous: 那三星不强啊 起刀很慢啊
Nicous: That three-star isn't strong, it attacks slowly.
Shure: 嗨
Shure: Hey.
Tasha: 你看啊
Tasha: Look.
Tasha: 它启动是慢
Tasha: Its start-up is slow.
Tasha: 因为我带的装备不对
Tasha: Because I equipped the wrong gear.
Shure: 我以为是构成一幅画呢
Shure: I thought it was supposed to form a picture.
Tasha: 不是带了个偷吗
Tasha: Didn't I equip a thief?
Katrina:  那那这些棒干了以后
Katrina: Then these sticks will dry.
Katrina: 再自己拼拼成一副画
Katrina: Then put it together to make a picture.
Katrina: 当然你也可以发挥你的创造力
Katrina: Of course, you can also use your creativity.
Katrina: 然后之后你就拿它干
Katrina: And then after that, you can use it for...
Katrina: 了以后它颜色也保存了
Katrina: After it's done, the color will be preserved.
Katrina: 你就拿胶水粘那种明信片啊
Katrina: You can use glue to stick it on a postcard or...
Nicous: 他是不是在砍你啊
Nicous: Is he cutting you off?
Katrina: 或者什么都可以
Katrina: Or anything, really.
Katrina: 或者夹玻璃片
Katrina: Or sandwich it with glass pieces.
Tasha: 他还有这种本领
Tasha: He has that kind of skill?
Tasha: 他怎么可能会有这种
Tasha: How could he possibly have that?
Nicous: 卖乌迪尔
Nicous: Selling Udyr.
Tasha: 卖谁
Tasha: Selling who?
Nicous: 卖乌迪尔
Nicous: Selling Udyr.
Nicous: 服 冲
Nicous: Serve, charge.
Shure: 我试试来然后呢
Shure: Let me try, then what?
Katrina: 没然后了
Katrina: There's no "then."
Katrina: 就把你压扁就行
Katrina: Just press it flat.
Katrina: 不是你多放点呗
Katrina: No, you should put more.
Shure: 什么叫多放一点
Shure: What do you mean by "put more"?
Tasha: 这就是你的指导
Nicous: 你怎么打别人
Nicous: How are you attacking others?
Tasha: 这就是你的指导
Tasha: 这些瓣也要压一下
Tasha: These petals also need to be pressed.
Tasha: 都受不了了
Tasha: I can't stand it anymore.
Katrina: 我觉得第一层先压薄的吧
Katrina: I think the first layer should be pressed thin.
Katrina: 这个放厚点
Katrina: This one should be thicker.
Katrina: 先压薄的就一片一片摆上去
Katrina: Start with thin layers, placing them one by one.
Tasha: 盖上一些小罐子我靠
Tasha: Cover it with some small jars, geez.
Tasha: 这就是你的
Tasha: This is yours.
Nicous: 笑死我了他有9个槽爪录下来了
Nicous: It cracks me up, he has 9 slots recorded.
Nicous: 一会他就学会了
Nicous: He'll learn it in a while.
Nicous: 一会要卖乌迪尔了别着急
Nicous: Soon he'll be selling Udyr, don't worry.
Tasha: 要卖力曾主
Tasha: Selling which champion?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Katrina: 你特别有一种
Katrina: You really have that vibe.
Katrina: 被妈妈送过去上那种兴趣班的
Katrina: Like a kid sent by mom to those hobby classes.
Katrina: 那种小孩
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: Sitting obediently.
Katrina: 坐着乖乖的
Katrina: Do you know what I mean?
俢硕：毫无感情是吧
Shure: Without any emotion, right?
Katrina: 对毫无感情
Katrina: Totally emotionless.
Katrina: 等你妈来接你回家的
Katrina: Waiting for your mom to pick you up.
Katrina: 我是那老师监督
Katrina: I'm supervising as the teacher.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure: 铺完了然后呢
Shure: After you finish, then what?
俢硕：怎么怎么盖
Shure: How do you cover this?
Shure: 这个东西
Shure: This thing.
Katrina: 我看看再放一点
Katrina: Let me see, add a bit more.
Katrina: 放满充分利用
Katrina: Fill it up and make full use of it.
Shure: 好好的轩老师
Shure: Well done, Teacher Xuan.
Katrina: 怎么都叫我轩老师
Katrina: Why does everyone call me Teacher Xuan?
Shure: 又忘了你姓啥了
Shure: Forgot your last name again.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 没有没有记着呢记着呢
Shure: No, no, I remember, I remember.
Shure: 节目效果懂吗
Shure: It's for the show's effect, you get it?
Katrina: 懂懂懂
Katrina: Got it, got it.
Katrina: 主要是之前那男生也叫我轩老师啊
Katrina: Mainly because that guy before also called me Teacher Xuan.
Shure: 完了勾起你不好意思回忆了是吗
Shure: Oh, did it bring up awkward memories for you?
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
俢硕：好的轩老师
Shure: Alright, Teacher Xuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈你达到了
Katrina: Hahaha, you did it.
俢硕：轩老师
Shure: Teacher Xuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈受不了了
Katrina: Hahaha, I can't take it.
Katrina: 她老师也这么叫我
Katrina: Even her teacher calls me that.
俢硕：嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
Nicous: 哪个前任还是这个
Nicous: Which ex, or this one?
Katrina: 这你就不知道了吧
Katrina: You wouldn't know.
Katrina: 昨天晚上新讲的一个
Katrina: A new story from last night.
Shure: 哦这个啊
Shure: Oh, that one.
Nicous: 哦
Nicous: Oh.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Nicous: 来对应的了
Nicous: Here we go.
Shure: 就是每天晚上解锁一个新角色
Shure: Unlocking a new character every night.
Nicous: 昨天晚上解锁的
Nicous: Last night's unlock.
Shure: 解锁了就到时候七个葫芦娃
Shure: Unlock them all and you'll have seven Calabash Brothers.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 昨天晚上我没来
Nicous: I wasn't here last night.
Shure: 就是白雪公主和七个小矮人
Shure: Like Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs.
Nicous: 我的那个百合花就永远的会了一下
Nicous: My lily will last forever.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake: 赢了吗
Jake: Did you win?
Tasha: 在谢民主的英明指导下
Tasha: Under the wise guidance of Xie Minzhu
Tasha: 我输掉了
Tasha: I lost
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 他指导我把人全卖了追人
Tasha: He advised me to sell everyone to chase people
Katrina: 你是人啊
Katrina: You are people
Jake:哦  怎么会输呢
Jake: Oh, how did you lose then?
Tasha: 你为什么在楼上
Tasha: Why are you upstairs?
Jake:因为我在看这个电池
Jake: Because I was looking at this battery
Jake:你知道这个电池是5号的
Jake: Do you know if this is a size AA
Jake:还是7号的吗
Jake: Or AAA battery?
Tasha: 我肯定可以知道
Tasha: I can definitely tell
Tasha: 5号
Tasha: AA
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you
Tasha: 今天下午干嘛玩啊
Tasha: What should we play this afternoon?
Jake:要不
Jake: How about
Jake:做狗他们在做狗吗
Jake: Play as dogs, are they playing as dogs?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No
Tasha: 我要干嘛
Tasha: What should I do?
Tasha: 关掉
Tasha: Turn it off
Tasha: then
Tasha: let me see see
Tasha: where are is
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 不好意思不好意思不好意思
Tasha: Sorry, sorry, sorry
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 给你看
Tasha: Look at this
Tasha: Look
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:嚯哦
Jake: Whoa
Tasha: 从此进我的房间就要脱鞋子了
Tasha: From now on, you have to take off your shoes to enter my room
Lucia: 哎你的地毯已经到了
Lucia: Oh, your carpet has arrived
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: It's so pretty
Lucia: 好多巴胺
Lucia: So much dopamine
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe
Lucia: 我目前到的材料还没有一个是蓝色的
Lucia: None of the materials I've received so far are blue
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 然后我让我许愿我的计划能顺利进行
Lucia: So I made a wish that my plan would go smoothly
Lucia: 这个剪刀有点不好使
Lucia: These scissors aren't working very well.
Jake: 是的你要不买点颜料
Jake: Yeah, maybe you should buy some paint.
Lucia: 我中途修一下计划
Lucia: I'll adjust the plan midway.
Jake:也可以看看有什么颜色
Jake: You can also check out the colors available.
Lucia: 然后到时候
Lucia: And then by that time...
Jake:你现在是什么颜色
Jake: What's your color now?
Lucia: 我现在都是白色的
Lucia: Right now, it's all white.
Jake:白色
Jake: White.
Lucia: 但我觉得它明天应该会到
Lucia: But I think it should arrive tomorrow.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 至少那个鱼网
Lucia: At least the fishnet.
Tasha: 这归我了
Tasha: This is mine.
Tasha: 这和我房间很配
Tasha: It matches my room perfectly.
Tasha: 哦要出门了是吧
Tasha: Oh, we're heading out, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 为什么我们一群人要看一只狗
Tasha: Why are we all watching a dog?
Tasha: 就感觉他是一个
Tasha: It feels like he's...
Tasha: 孤独的需要被看望的
Tasha: Lonely and needs someone to visit him.
Tasha: 空巢老人一样
Tasha: Like an empty nester.
Lucia: 建立一些逻辑联系
Lucia: Build some logical connections.
Tasha: 哦 是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Lucia: 就知道这两个关键词
Lucia: Just know these two keywords.
Jake:是我们要做狗
Jake: We're going to be dogs.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 那我要做一只可爱小狗
Tasha: Then I want to be a cute little dog.
Jake:小狗 好嘞
Jake: A little dog, got it.
Tasha: 所以昨天为什么要抢红包
Tasha: So why were we grabbing red envelopes yesterday?
Tasha: 明明这是用
Tasha: Clearly, it's about...
Katrina: 手速得来
Katrina: Hand speed.
Jake:因为他没有钱是吧
Jake: Because he has no money, right?
Tasha: 结果今天大家还是一样的
Tasha: But today, everyone is still the same.
Jake:那提前拿到钱嘛多好
Jake: Getting the money in advance is great.
Shure: 非常懂
Shure: Totally get it.
Jake:非常懂
Jake: Totally get it.
Katrina: 就是知道了你座以后才能大概猜一下你性格
Katrina: It's only after knowing your sign that I can guess your personality.
Shure: 那上那上另一个HAP上找找去哈哈哈
Shure: Then go search on another HAP, hahaha.
Jake:天秤秤
Jake: Libra.
Jake:十月份差不多
Jake: Around October.
Jake:天秤座也很
Jake: Libras are also...
Katrina: 前男友天秤座
Katrina: My ex was a Libra.
Shure: 他是风相
Shure: He is an air sign.
Shure: 风相就是
Shure: An air sign means...
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 对就是每天都是
Shure: Yeah, it means every day...
Shure: 还想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: He wants to talk to you about the universe and the sky.
Shure: 或是沙滩里的碎石和人生
Shure: Or the pebbles on the beach and life.
Shure: 哦就是这个样子的一个人
Shure: Oh, he's just that kind of person.
Shure: 然后呢这是第几次
Shure: So, how many times is this?
Katrina: 整不明白
Katrina: I don't get it.
Katrina: 说什么这个吗嗯
Katrina: Are you talking about this? Hmm.
Shure: 我想快压一次
Shure: I want to press it quickly.
Katrina: 但是我去这么厚这个能压吗
Katrina: But it's so thick, can it be pressed?
Shure: 我就想把它就是这个垮给还原出来
Shure: I just want to restore that collapse.
Katrina: 但是应该要把这拔一下
Katrina: But you should pull this out.
Katrina: 反正这太硬了它压不下去
Katrina: Anyway, it's too hard to press down.
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这个样子
Shure: Hahaha, why are you like this?
Katrina: 但是我妈让我学师范
Katrina: But my mom wants me to study education.
Katrina: 我说你觉得我能学师范
Katrina: I said, do you think I can study education?
Katrina: 我打小孩
Katrina: I hit children.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 棍棒底下出孝子
Shure: Spare the rod, spoil the child.
Shure: 严师出高徒
Shure: Strict teachers produce outstanding students.
Katrina: 哇这个大花瓣
Katrina: Wow, this big petal.
Shure: 这个话不无道理
Shure: There's some truth in that saying.
Shure: 你给他拆了
Shure: You dismantled it.
Shure: 我就想让他整一个这样子
Shure: I just want him to make one like this.
Katrina: 整一个这个压不了啊
Katrina: Making this can't be pressed.
Katrina: 除非你一天到晚用屁股坐着他才能压
Katrina: Unless you sit on it all day long, then it might press.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 蛮敬业的哟
Katrina: Very dedicated, huh.
Lucia: 那咱每次吃饭的时候就坐在上面
Lucia: Then every time we eat, we sit on it.
Katrina: 能长痔疮
Katrina: You'll get hemorrhoids.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia: 这样能让他干的就是
Lucia: This way, it can be done...
Lucia: 说更平一点
Lucia: ...flatter.
Lucia: 只要接触空调就会缩水
Lucia: As long as it comes into contact with the air conditioner, it will shrink.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈那应该不至于
Shure: Hahahaha, that shouldn't be the case.
Lucia: 哇你的窗帘是吧
Lucia: Wow, is that your curtain?
Shure: 这就是充满爱意和
Shure: It's full of love and...
Lucia: 这个是雨轩的吗
Lucia: Is this Yuxuan's?
Lucia: 是那种蜡烛式的吗
Lucia: Is it like a candle?
Lucia: 好好看等你拆了记得叫我观摩一下
Lucia: Looks great! When you open it, remember to let me watch.
Lucia: 其实我今天打开了这个盒子
Lucia: Actually, I opened this box today
Lucia: 发现里面还有一层盒子
Lucia: and found another box inside.
Lucia: 你没有拆过
Lucia: You haven't opened it yet.
Lucia: 我就决定先留着让你拆
Lucia: So I decided to leave it for you to open.
Katrina: 我也不知道长啥样呢
Katrina: I don't know what it looks like either.
Katrina: 万一跟那个色吸食物
Katrina: What if it matches the other stuff?
Jake:走看狗去
Jake: Let's go see the dog.
Jake:可以了吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Katrina: i'm ready now
Katrina: I'm ready now.
Jake:狗狗
Jake: Doggy!
Lucia: 哦好看
Lucia: Oh, it looks great.
Jake:快去
Jake: Hurry up!
Katrina: 谁啊还有还有人呢
Katrina: Who else is there? Is anyone else coming?
Jake:柯欣呢
Jake: Where's Ke Xin?
Katrina: 全体吗
Katrina: Everyone?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Anyone can come.
Katrina: 穿睡衣应该没问题
Katrina: Wearing pajamas should be fine.
Lucia: 这是一个自由选择的副本
Lucia: This is a free choice mission.
Katrina: 跟遛弯一样
Katrina: Like taking a walk.
Jake:对就是遛弯
Jake: Yes, just like a walk.
Jake:我我我压花
Jake: I'm pressing flowers.
Shure: 然后一直坐着他
Shure: And then you just sit on it.
Jake:那个能孵出糖花来
Jake: That can hatch sugar flowers.
Tasha: 盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Lucia: 这压花的意思其实是压在花上是吧
Lucia: Pressing flowers means pressing on the flowers, right?
Tasha: 盐呢盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt? Where's the salt?
Tasha: 盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Jake:走走走咿呀走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Katrina: 对我要做一下我的手工任务
Katrina: Right, I need to do my craft task.
Katrina: 火很重的
Katrina: The fire is heavy.
Tasha: 昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did we use salt yesterday?
Shure: 昨天好像没怎么用盐
Shure: I don't think we used much salt yesterday.
Tasha: 盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Shure: 哦如果我想把它压成花的样
Shure: Oh, if I want to press it into a flower shape,
Shure: 我要让他屁股冲上是吗
Shure: I should have its bottom facing up, right?
Shure: 嗯然后他的屁股冲上
Shure: Yeah, and then its bottom facing up.
Lucia: 渴了
Lucia: Thirsty.
Shure: 盐呢
Shure: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 然后这种的话我看人家都是侧着压的
Katrina: And for this, I've seen people pressing it sideways.
Tasha: 盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha: 盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 随便你自己发挥吧
Katrina: Just go ahead and do your thing.
Jake:盐什么盐
Jake: Salt, what salt?
Tasha: 盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Shure: OK那就这样
Shure: OK, that's it then.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Lucia: 盐
Lucia: Salt.
Shure: 老师摆的很好
Shure: Teacher placed it well.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Shure: 然后下一步应该给他盖上盖
Shure: Next step, we should cover it up.
Tasha: 盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:没盐了
Katrina: 那就
Katrina: Then...
Jake:我能这么能吃
Jake: How can I eat so much?
Tasha: 不可能呀
Tasha: Impossible.
Jake:不能吃压个两层
Jake: Can't eat, press two layers.
Katrina: 压个两层吧
Katrina: Press two layers then.
Lucia: 没桃了还有可能没盐应该不至于吧
Lucia: Ran out of peaches, running out of salt should be unlikely, right?
Lucia: 有可能盐
Lucia: Maybe the salt...
Lucia: 没盐应该不至于吧
Lucia: Running out of salt should be unlikely, right?
Shure: 再加一层呢
Shure: How about adding another layer?
Tasha: 盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 直接给他上两层干燥吧
Katrina: Just go ahead and dry it in two layers.
Katrina: 感觉这个有点难度呀
Katrina: Feels a bit difficult.
Jake:能在哪呢
Jake: Where could it be?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: Don't know.
Jake:应该都在这吧
Jake: Should all be here.
Lucia: 是不是昨天烧烤的时候拿出去用过
Lucia: Was it taken out for barbecue yesterday?
Tasha: 不在问了
Tasha: Not asking anymore.
Lucia: 但是那也应该拿回来了吧
Lucia: But it should have been brought back, right?
Tasha: 可恶
Tasha: Damn it.
Tasha: 谁把盐给偷走了
Tasha: Who stole the salt?
Lucia: 我们有勺了
Lucia: We've got a spoon.
Jake:对买勺了
Jake: Yeah, we bought a spoon.
Jake:盐没盐了怎么办
Jake: What do we do if there's no salt?
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Just leave it.
Lucia: 我先在这组装
Lucia: I'll assemble this first.
Lucia: 一会出发了叫我
Lucia: Call me when we're leaving.
Lucia: 说明书上哪了在这
Lucia: Where's the manual? Here it is.
Lucia: 啊这玩意装完了我还得给他
Lucia: Ah, after assembling this, I still have to...
Lucia: 到时候再拆一次
Lucia: Dismantle it once more later.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt?
Tasha: 不要了
Tasha: Forget it.
Jake:盐在这
Jake: The salt's here.
Tasha: 饿了 有没有要吃地瓜
Tasha: I'm hungry. Anyone want some sweet potato?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake:但是我们先去看狗吧
Jake: But let's check on the dog first.
Tasha: 看狗半个小时
Tasha: Check on the dog for half an hour.
Jake:好半小时绰绰有余
Jake: Okay, half an hour is more than enough.
Tasha: 10分钟
Tasha: 10 minutes.
Jake:多久啊一般
Jake: How long usually?
Jake:狗能看个10分钟吗
Jake: Can we check on the dog for 10 minutes?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走吧出发
Jake: Let's head out.
Tasha: 你不去是吗
Tasha: You're not coming?
Shure: 我不去
Shure: I'm not going.
Tasha: 你能在4：32的时候把火给关掉吗
Tasha: Can you turn off the fire at 4:32?
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 定个闹钟
Katrina: Set an alarm.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 帮我定个4：32闹钟
Shure: Help me set an alarm for 4:32.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Lucia: 哎准备走了好吧
Lucia: Hey, let's get ready to leave, okay?
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 等我回来再接着安排
Lucia: I'll continue when I get back.
Tasha: 衣服
Tasha: Clothes.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:露亚不去吗
Jake: Lucia's not coming?
Jake:没人的
Jake: No one's here.
Jake:走 带路 皇军得带路
Jake: Go, lead the way. The army needs to lead the way.
Jake:不用扣上
Jake: No need to fasten it.
Jake:没关系的我
Jake: It's okay, I...
Lucia: 不好意思你回答晚了
Lucia: Sorry, you answered too late.
Jake:答晚了
Jake: Answered too late.
Jake:赛博小队
Jake: Cyber squad.
Jake:慧欣你带充电器了没
Jake: Huixin, did you bring the charger?
Jake:好的强 牛逼
Jake: Okay, strong. Awesome.
Jake:你有吗
Jake: Do you have it?
Jake:你没有
Jake: You don't?
Lucia: 我当然有了
Lucia: Of course I have it.
Jake:强
Jake: Strong.
Jake:哎 猫
Jake: Hey, a cat.
Lucia: 噢看见了
Lucia: Oh, I see it.
Jake:这是韭菜吗
Jake: Is this chives?
Lucia: 我以为这是大葱因为上面有头
Lucia: I thought it's green onions because there's a bulb on top.
Lucia: 就是葱花
Lucia: It's scallions.
Jake:每个人都有不同的解读
Jake: Everyone has a different interpretation.
Lucia: 这话五谷不分呢
Lucia: This shows you don't know your grains.
Lucia: 好香哦
Lucia: It smells so good.
Tasha: 丁香吧
Tasha: It's cloves.
Lucia: 拔一搓去做压花
Lucia: Pull some out and press them into flower.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:拔 拔一点可以
Jake: Pull, pull a bit, it's okay.
Tasha: 啊好香呀
Tasha: Ah, it smells so good.
Lucia: 回来路上再拔
Lucia: Pull some on the way back.
Jake:等等等等等等
Jake: Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Tasha: 多多麻嘚
Tasha: Much, much appreciated.
Tasha: 这家也种这个呀
Tasha: This house grows them too.
Tasha: 行那你吃一个
Tasha: Alright, then you eat one.
Jake:哈哈哈不太圆
Jake: Hahaha, not very round.
Jake:我已经准备好了
Jake: I'm already prepared.
Lucia: 给您准备好了
Lucia: Got it ready for you.
Jake:不太圆这葡萄啊
Jake: This grape is not very round.
Tasha: 这么快
Tasha: So quick.
Tasha: 阿布
Tasha: Abu.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Lucia: 嘴巴一直在咬
Lucia: Its mouth is always chewing.
小狗老板：它爱咬这种它喜欢这种托鞋
Puppy Boss: It loves chewing this kind, it likes these slippers.
Jake:噢吃了吗
Jake: Oh, did it eat?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 好多人他都闻不过来了
Lucia: So many people, he can't sniff them all
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:他有名字吗
Jake: Does he have a name?
Tasha: 卡布
Tasha: Cap
Jake:卡布
Jake: Cap
Jake:这颜色确实
Jake: This color is really...
Alice:啊给我只小兔子
Alice: Ah, give me a bunny
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Hahaha, brilliant!
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:小狗味 可爱吧你说
Alice: Puppy smell, isn't it cute?
小狗老板：它才洗了两三天澡就搁这打滚成这样了
Nicous: He just had a bath two or three days ago, and now he's rolling around like this
Jake:呵呵确实爱咬人
Jake: Haha, he really loves to bite
Jake:确实爱咬人
Jake: He really loves to bite
Jake:咬你了吧
Jake: He bit you, didn't he?
Lucia: 突然舔一口
Lucia: Suddenly licked
Jake:舔噢
Jake: Licked, huh?
Jake:他为什么尽咬我
Jake: Why does he keep biting me?
Lucia: 你看起来像磨牙棒
Lucia: You look like a chew toy
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:对有很多摄像头
Jake: Yeah, there are a lot of cameras
Jake:这我们在做研究的时候
Jake: When we're doing research
小狗老板：哦 科技产品
Nicous: Oh, tech products
Jake:科技产品
Jake: Tech products
Jake:就是我们在这转一圈
Jake: When we walk around this place
Jake:你们这房子就 重现出来了
Jake: Your house gets recreated
小狗老板：被你们拍摄下来了
Nicous: Captured by you guys
Jake:就是重现 就是有一个3D模型对
Jake: It's recreated, with a 3D model, yeah
小狗老板：建模
Nicous: Modeling
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:然后这狗
Jake: And then this dog
Jake:如果不动的话也可以把它建出来
Jake: If it stays still, it can be modeled too
Jake:但是现在没办法
Jake: But right now, no way
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 这不能咬
Lucia: This can't be bitten
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 线不能咬
Lucia: The wire can't be bitten
Lucia: 别的地方你都可以咬
Lucia: You can bite other places
Jake:对线不能咬
Jake: Yeah, can't bite the wire
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake:现在我们还差根管
Jake: Now we're still missing a tube.
Jake:每人插管
Jake: Everyone needs a tube.
小狗老板：这是科技新
Dog Boss: This is new technology.
Jake:这这还不是产品
Jake: This is not a product yet.
Jake:这没有量产
Jake: It's not mass-produced.
Jake:还买不着
Jake: You can't buy it yet.
Lucia: 实验阶段
Lucia: It's still in the experimental stage.
小狗老板：那你们这是一家什么公司
Dog Boss: So what kind of company is this?
Jake:呃是算学校学校的研究
Jake: Uh, it's kind of a school research project.
小狗老板：学校的
Dog Boss: School?
Jake:学校 对
Jake: School, yeah.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:然后这产品是那个
Jake: And this product is, um...
Jake:叫什么脸书脸书脸书Face book mate
Jake: What's it called, Facebook, Facebook, Facebook Face book mate.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:就是一个8000美元
Jake: It's like $8000.
小狗老板：天呢
Dog Boss: Oh my god.
小狗老板：这一会我这院子里就值钱了
Dog Boss: My yard will be worth a fortune soon.
小狗老板：那你们这什么学校
Dog Boss: So what school are you from?
Jake:我们来至不同的学校
Jake: We're from different schools.
Jake:但是这个实验室是这个南亚理工的
Jake: But this lab is from South Asian Poly.
Jake:新加坡 我从新加坡过来的
Jake: Singapore. I came from Singapore.
小狗老板：我一个大学同学他在去南亚理工读过书然后
Dog Boss: I had a college classmate who went to South Asian Poly, and then...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:他还知道跑过去
Jake: He knew to go there?
Jake:哦哪个学校
Jake: Oh, which school?
小狗老板：我是
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
小狗老板：然后他是在三亚上完学之后
Dog Boss: And then he finished school in Sanya and then...
小狗老板：好像先去的我那个
Dog Boss: I think he first went to my...
小狗老板：宿舍同学先去的
Dog Boss: Dorm mate went first.
小狗老板：人大读研在去的
Dog Boss: He went to Renmin University for a master's and then...
小狗老板：南亚理工读的那个博士
Dog Boss: Went to South Asian Poly for a PhD.
Jake:噢 OK OK  校友啊
Jake: Oh, OK, OK. Alumni!
Jake:为什么跑这么远
Jake: Why go so far?
Jake:他为啥跑这么远
Jake: Why did he go so far?
Alice:阿布
Alice: Abu.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Nicous: 旺旺旺
Nicous: Woof woof woof.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:拉粑粑
Alice: Pooping
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:他应该是在哪拿的
Jake: Where did he get it from?
Jake:也没地
Jake: There's no place
Lucia: 卡布
Lucia: Kabu
Jake:是他在叫吗
Jake: Is he the one calling?
Alice:小狗尖叫
Alice: The puppy is screaming
Alice:卡布 过来
Alice: Kabu, come here
Alice:狗狗碎碎
Alice: The puppy is scattered
Tasha: 哈哈 强行坐下
Tasha: Haha, forcefully sitting down
Alice:摇头晃脑的
Alice: Shaking its head
Alice:它想咬东西
Alice: It wants to bite something
Jake:他这衣服是干嘛的
Jake: What's with his clothes?
Jake:能被提起来吗
Jake: Can it be lifted?
Alice:溜的吧
Alice: It's for walking
Jake:哦溜的是吧
Jake: Oh, it's for walking
Alice:狗绳
Alice: A dog leash
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:单手拎
Jake: Single-handed lift
Jake:塑料袋
Jake: Plastic bag
Jake:唉我去 这是边牧吧
Jake: Oh my, is this a Border Collie?
Alice:你管掉了
Alice: Do you care if it falls?
Nicous: 它拉粑粑了
Nicous: It pooped
Alice:门口
Alice: At the door
小狗老板：你可真会拉
Puppy Owner: You really know how to poop
Nicous: 该打
Nicous: Should be punished
小狗老板：讨厌
Puppy Owner: Annoying
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Ouch
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:教训教训
Jake: Teach a lesson
Jake:挨教训了
Jake: Getting a lesson
Jake:挨打了
Jake: Getting hit
Nicous: 还咬 又 又要挨一拳
Nicous: Biting again, gonna get punched again
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:打了吗
Jake: Did it get hit?
Lucia: 他打疫苗了吧
Lucia: Did he get vaccinated?
Lucia: 那他刚在我手上咬了一下
Lucia: He just bit my hand
小狗老板：没事没事
Puppy Owner: It's okay, it's okay
Lucia: 居然没烂
Lucia: It didn't even break
Nicous: 没烂没事
Nicous: It's not rotten, it's fine.
小狗老板：哦没出血不
Dog Boss: Oh, is there no bleeding?
Lucia: 没有就是稍微这样刮了一下
Lucia: No, just a slight scratch like this.
小狗老板：哦犬舍说它打过了
Dog Boss: Oh, the kennel said it was vaccinated.
Lucia: 我有必要现在去打个疫苗吗
Lucia: Do I need to get a vaccine now?
Lucia: 应该没破的时候
Lucia: It shouldn't be broken.
Jake:应该没事没事
Jake: It should be fine, no worries.
小狗老板：啊这也没事
Dog Boss: Ah, it's fine.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: No worries.
Lucia: 啊那就行
Lucia: Ah, that's good.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
小狗老板：别让它咬着
Dog Boss: Don't let it bite you.
小狗老板：它打是打了我们就是怕犬舍没打好
Dog Boss: It was vaccinated, but we worry the kennel didn't do it properly.
小狗老板：回头在给它重新打一遍
Dog Boss: We'll get it vaccinated again later.
Alice:嗨
Alice: Hi.
Jake:嚯 这么能咬
Jake: Whoa, such a bite!
Jake:我去 直接咬下去了
Jake: Oh my, it bit right down.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my.
Jake:好吃吗
Jake: Does it taste good?
Alice:卡布 卡布
Alice: Kabu, Kabu.
小狗老板：接哥哥去了晚上来接你哈
Dog Boss: I'm picking up my brother, I'll come pick you up tonight, okay?
小狗老板：走了 再见 拜拜
Dog Boss: We're leaving. Goodbye, bye-bye.
Alice:就这么敢路程过来咬
Alice: It came all the way here just to bite.
Jake:喜欢托鞋
Jake: It likes slippers.
Nicous: 它这个是长牙要换牙那个
Nicous: It's growing teeth, it's gonna replace them.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Nicous: 然后它就是所以就是拿牙去衡量去体会
Nicous: So it's using its teeth to measure and experience things.
Alice:牙咬
Alice: Teeth bite.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Alice:啃完左右啃又脚
Alice: It gnaws left and right, then on the feet.
Jake:当手用
Jake: Using them like hands.
Jake:咬石头
Jake: Biting stones.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Aiya.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 皮
Tasha: Naughty.
Jake:呃你你你们没有脸
Jake: Uh, you guys don't have faces.
Jake:就是你们会被打码
Jake: I mean, you'll be censored.
Jake:对 放心
Jake: Yeah, don't worry.
Jake:所有的人包括我们也没有脸
Jake: None of us have a face, including us.
小狗老板：就是打马赛克是吧
Dog Boss: You mean pixelate, right?
Alice:来玩呗
Alice: Come on, let's play.
Alice:小狗
Alice: Puppy.
Alice:啊它露肚皮了
Alice: Ah, it's showing its belly.
Jake:哎 它还有一个画像
Jake: Hey, it has a portrait.
Jake:唉 我去
Jake: Oh my, seriously?
Jake:有点想提它 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Kind of want to pick it up, haha.
Jake:是没提起来啊
Jake: Couldn't lift it, huh?
Tasha: 哎哟
Tasha: Oh my.
Jake:哎哟我去不给提
Jake: Oh my, can't lift it.
Jake:回去回去
Jake: Go back, go back.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Alice:过来
Alice: Come here.
Alice:过来 咬鞋子
Alice: Come here, biting shoes.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:它刚刚摔着了吗
Jake: Did it just fall?
Jake:嚯 它又找那个啥玩意
Jake: Whoa, it's looking for that thing again.
Alice:给这死缠
Alice: Give it a tight grip.
Jake:把你提起来
Jake: Lift you up.
Jake:哎  不行不行不行这个不行 这个不行
Jake: Oh no, no, no, this can't work, this can't work.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:给提起来啦
Alice: Lifted it up.
Jake:完了 互换攻击了
Jake: Done, switched attacks.
Jake:想那么逗猫你逗它
Jake: Want to tease it like a cat, go tease it.
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Oh my.
Alice:吓死我啦
Alice: Scared me to death.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 村里头流浪的小动物好多吧
Nicous: There are lots of stray animals in the village, right?
Jake:嗯 是
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Nicous: 那个好多好多猫
Nicous: So many cats.
Nicous: 然后这个这个程序里面就是流浪的猫
Nicous: And in this program, there are stray cats.
Nicous: 就是看到过先罗
Nicous: Seen a lot of exotic breeds.
Nicous: 看见过好多名贵的品种
Nicous: Seen so many precious breeds.
小狗老板：先罗 布偶
Dog Boss: Siamese, Ragdoll.
Nicous: 啊对 都有
Nicous: Yeah, they have it all.
小狗老板：里面都有各种名犬名猫
Dog Boss: They have all kinds of famous dogs and cats.
Jake:这么有意思 为啥在这
Jake: That's so interesting, why here?
Tasha: 为啥流浪了呀
Tasha: Why are they strays?
小狗老板：不知道全跑那屋里
Dog Boss: No idea, they all ran into that room.
Nicous: 你说收了多少只猫
Nicous: How many cats have you collected?
Jake:上哪去了
Jake: Where did they go?
小狗老板：一个有一个马桶
Dog Boss: There's a toilet in each room.
小狗老板：我家有四个还是六个忘了
Dog Boss: I can't remember if I have four or six.
小狗老板：最多是六个马桶 就是一人一个
Dog Boss: At most, six toilets, one for each person.
小狗老板：它不在这里面尿 它就去别的地方尿
Dog Boss: If it doesn't pee here, it'll pee somewhere else.
Alice:领地
Alice: Territory.
小狗老板：它的占地意识特别强
Dog Boss: It has a very strong sense of territory.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
小狗老板：这只猫啊和我一个马桶 每天尿到哪里都是
Dog Boss: This cat shares my toilet, pees everywhere every day.
Jake:它这是要干你了它这个
Jake: It's trying to dominate you.
Jake:这个姿势
Jake: Look at its posture.
Alice:我也没惹你呀 你把我鞋咬成这样了
Alice: I didn't even provoke you, and you chewed my shoes like this.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:我都没在乎呢
Alice: I don't even mind.
Alice:咬吧咬吧
Alice: Bite, bite away.
Jake:干哈你干哈
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:看地瓜去吧
Jake: Go check the sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 这么害怕
Tasha: So scared.
Alice:很乖呀
Alice: Very obedient.
Nicous: 哦呀 被发现了
Nicous: Oh, got caught.
Alice:是不是血统比较纯的那种
Alice: Is it a purebred?
Alice:因为它爪子得很肥很厚实
Alice: Because its paws are very fat and solid.
Jake:这这怎么看这很容易看吗
Jake: How can you tell? Is it that easy?
Alice:就看它的爪子
Alice: Just look at its paws.
Jake:哈这么讲究
Jake: Oh, that particular?
小狗老板：它还挺亲人
Dog Boss: It's quite affectionate.
小狗老板：啥名
Dog Boss: What's its name?
小狗老板：卡布 我们家有一只大秋田
Dog Boss: Kabu. We have a big Akita at home.
小狗老板：长大了这可拆家了
Dog Boss: When it grows up, it'll tear the house apart.
小狗老板：真的 它精力太旺盛了
Dog Boss: Really, it's got so much energy.
小狗老板：喜欢咬线磨牙呢
Dog Boss: Likes to chew on wires to grind its teeth.
小狗老板：哦你的牙齿还挺锋
Dog Boss: Oh, your teeth are quite sharp.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
小狗老板：它真是在磨牙 见啥都咬
Dog Boss: It's really grinding its teeth, chewing on everything.
小狗老板：其实我觉得狗这么小的时候挺好玩的
Dog Boss: Actually, I think dogs are really fun when they're this small.
小狗老板：这是几个月啊这个狗
Dog Boss: How many months old is this dog?
小狗老板：两个月挺好的
Dog Boss: Two months, that's good.
小狗老板：长大就比秋田小点
Dog Boss: When it grows up, it'll be a bit smaller than an Akita.
Jake:走吧 要不
Jake: Let's go, shall we?
Tasha: 好 还是金毛粘人
Tasha: Sure, Golden Retrievers are really clingy.
Jake:还能去哪里了
Jake: Where else can we go?
Tasha: 好像是唉
Tasha: Seems like it.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Nicous: 那边那个绿色的她说
Nicous: She said the green one over there.
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Tasha: 哦哈
Tasha: Oh, got it.
Jake:还有附近还有啥啊
Jake: Anything else nearby?
Nicous: 没了
Nicous: Nope.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:烤地瓜去吧
Jake: Let's go roast some sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:哈 烤地瓜
Jake: Haha, roast sweet potatoes!